okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of history of science and
technology q a
and i'm happy to try and answer
questions about aspects of history of
science or technology are the ones that
i've been involved in myself or ones
that i might have studied
so let's see we have a number of
questions
that have come in or saved up from
previous times
there's one from andrew here
saying i think there's been a concerted
and focused effort to give greater
emphasis to stem education since world
war ii
has the history of science been left out
in this process
interesting question you know i have to
say i have sometimes objected to the
fact that some subjects
are taught
were at least taught very much in their
historical order physics is one of those
it's like
people teach kind of traditional physics
and then they teach what's called modern
physics well modern physics is now
physics from a century ago it's things
like well maybe relativity
uh quantum mechanics those date from you
know relativity in 1905 quantum
mechanics 1920s and so on that's that's
called modern physics but it's thought
to be kind of you know that's that's
very kind of sophisticated uh modern
stuff
that shouldn't be taught at first
whether it's always correct to teach
things in the historical order is an
interesting one i mean for instance in
well one thing that has been sort of a
surprise in the history of science is
the idea of computation and the idea of
computers and so on which originated in
well it sort of began in the 1920s 1930s
kind of got full steam in the in the
1950s 1960s and so on as actual digital
electronic computers came online but the
notion this idea of computation is
actually something you can explain
to
pretty young kids at this point now
perhaps that is because we have ambient
computers and computation in our kind of
everyday world or perhaps it's because
the concept actually isn't that hard to
understand once you've managed to sort
of climb the hill to get there it's just
our civilization took a really long time
to get there
so i think there are these cases where
things have tended to be explained
historically when it's not clear that's
the best thing to do now next question
is is it worth teaching the history of
how ideas came to be i think absolutely
yes i mean i think it is it is uh
sort of to contextualize
why we believe the things we believe and
how convincing it is
that those things are really the way
they are and so on and also the the i
think one of the one of the things about
history of science
that is interesting if it's presented in
in sort of the right way is if you're
learning about science to some extent it
is only you're just getting kind of uh
sort of the wisdom the teacher gives you
so to speak and it's all disembodied and
there's no concept that a person figured
these things out that somebody had to
figure this out at some point it's all
just sort of uh delivered wisdom so to
speak that isn't doesn't have the notion
that a person had to make it up i mean
you know i kind of notice
in um
in technology situations this phenomenon
that people don't really internalize the
idea that humans have to make things
like software i i noticed this
particularly in in times before the
pandemic when i would uh
be traveling around and i i'd give some
talk to some group of kids or something
and uh they know my name and they'd say
oh you know then they say you know they
realized it's sort of connected to
wolfman alpha which is pretty widely
used um
and uh and they'd kind of have this this
moment where they realized wait a minute
that's the name of this person that's
the name of the software there must be
some relationship between these two
things and it's like yes actual humans
create software so to speak and i think
sometimes it's some uh you know even
when in a sense there's a person's name
on some scientific law or some such
other thing there's a certain
disembodiment of um the uh of kind of
the fact that somebody had to figure
that out at some point and knowing how
things got figured out is often really
interesting
i mean i think that um
uh
you know there's a there's a bit of kind
of a twist of complexity here because
sometimes things got figured out wrong
before they got figured out right
like for instance let's say you could
teach the theory of phlogiston for
example before you teach thermodynamics
that would probably be confusing
probably not sure i haven't really
thought that one through
um you could teach
about the ether before you teach
relativity
uh
and you know is that confusing or is
that helpful i'm not sure
i think in some cases
it's sort of
okay there are things where there is an
intuitive sense of what might be going
on that the everyday person would get
and perhaps that's how things were
thought about in the history of science
at first and then somebody realized oh
the intuitive way of thinking about it
isn't right actually this is the thing
that's right and perhaps that's a useful
thing to be able to see that this is a
way you might have thought about it just
thinking about it from scratch but
actually what the science does is to
show that that isn't the correct thing
and that's perhaps an interesting
transition to see
but i think that the um uh
uh you know in in
no i i tend to think it's a little bit
of a complicated story because i think
that this idea of do you teach what was
thought but it was wrong
and then teach what was right
do you teach only the sort of latest
thing or do you teach kind of the
sequence of how people got to that thing
i think it's sort of a mixture that's
needed i think it's also worth
uh but i also think that the there is a
certain value to being able to
personalize scientific discovery and
give some sense of what uh sort of the
the what the flow was what the you know
what the achievements were that led to
certain kinds of scientific results
the question here
um
so aaron quotes nassim talaba saying
that engineering precedes theory even in
projects such as jet propulsion
can i think of historical counter
examples where theory preceded
engineering
oh that's an interesting question
um
i mean the typical flow tends to be
that
one
i mean the real question is does
theoretical science is theoretical
science successful
and the usual flow is a methodology for
experimentation is developed
microscopes are developed then people
realize oh you can look through a
microscope and you can understand lots
of stuff about biology
biology is not a great example where you
know theory leads to um to practice well
i would say that
many many pharma startups
start with a theory
or at least some level of theory oh if
we do this to confuse the immune system
this is what's going to happen
and that will produce a useful therapy
for example
or some other kind of conceptual theory
um so i think it would be unfair to say
that i mean i think there are plenty of
places where people say i wonder if this
is how this is going to work and then
they actually build some whole
thing that might turn into a drug that
then gets tested and most of the time
unfortunately will fail um and then
perhaps it makes it through to the final
things i think that's one case where
where a conceptual theory at least
precedes the practice now when it comes
to um
uh let's see i'm trying to think of
examples where
um
i mean there are many examples where
people have
wondered
um i don't know i don't know why i'm
thinking of ion propulsion
um you know i think
in the case yeah even in the case of
rocketry yeah basic rocketry you know
newton's third law that says if you push
the
exhaust out of the rocket one way the
rocket will go forward the other way um
that was a thing that was very much a
theoretically uh uh you know known thing
now you could argue well people had seen
things where where i don't know people
had seen examples of that where peop
somebody had sort of built it as
engineering before uh before there was a
theory by the time people like goddard
were were trying to do rocketry i think
they understood newton's third law
really really quite well
now i think um
uh i'm sure there are many examples from
um
um
well okay another example which i think
is kind of a bad example
um because i don't think it's quite uh
headed on a good track
is quantum computing
where kind of the the theory of quantum
mechanics
long preceded any any effort to do that
um
perhaps there are other examples well
artificial satellites that's another
example artificial satellites that's a
that's a pretty dramatic example
where
you
you know the engineering of uh the fact
that you could imagine that you could
stick something in orbit around the
earth
was something i suppose you could say
well okay we can see moons orbiting
jupiter or something but the fact that
it was a thing that you could imagine
actually doing
as a thing around the earth is something
that was sort of known from the physics
of mechanics
um before it was known there now another
example ah yes a much better example
much better example is radio i think
heinrich hertz
was investigating the consequences of
maxwell's equations when he invented
radio
and i think that was a thing where it
was the theory of electromagnetic waves
that led to the idea that you could
perhaps make a radio
rather than i think hertz originally
when people said okay you know i think
his original experiment was just you
have something that was some kind of
spark gap that was generating
electromagnetic radiation here and that
was at a distance it was affecting
something over here and i think when
people first asked him what's this going
to be good for he said i don't really
know
and um uh you know it came only later
with people like marconi that there was
sort of this real realization that radio
was a technology that you could uh make
serious use of so i think that's a
that's a pretty good example of of where
uh the theory really did precede i
believe um any engineering effort
and really the theory so stimulated the
engineering effort
um i would say that uh
well yeah i think there are probably
lots of examples of that
aaron also asked talk about times in
history when scientific knowledge was
destroyed and why that occurred
yeah it's interesting i mean people talk
about different kinds of things where i
don't know like metals that were used
alloys that were used in you know to
make the the most amazing sword and so
on back in i don't know 500 years ago or
something and we don't know how that's
made anymore and i think some of the
some of the weirdest cases of that are
where where things like swords were made
from metal that came from meteorites
which were sort of super rare and you
know only the king so to speak got the
sword that was made out of meteorite
metal um but i think there are places
there where the making of an alloy is
not is not um it's not understood it's
actually a little surprising to me now
that i think about it because i don't
know why you can't just take it apart
and see the atomic constituents that
were made there i mean there are plenty
of things in kind of um artisanal
construction whether it's you know how
to make the perfect violin
things like this
where uh you know you can look at the
finished product but it's not obvious
how it was made um and those are places
where i think things have been sort of
somewhat lost but if you ask about
kind of
science
and more theoretical science
i think
a very common thing that happens is
somebody will have sort of figured
something more or less out
but
it doesn't get
clearly enough explained
or it is something for which the context
doesn't exist at the time when it's
figured out and it's sort of lost
potentially for a long period of time
i mean i i think
um
i'm trying to think of examples um i'm
not sure that mendel was quite an
example
with his genetics but there have been
examples in
in
what's a good example
you know something like charles darwin's
origin of species you know book comes
out big success you know off to a grand
start
but i could imagine and there were even
predecessors of the natural selection
theory that had kind of come and gone
and they weren't very well explained and
it wasn't as clearly you know it wasn't
didn't sort of come at the right time in
the right way
um and so i think there are there are
plenty of examples of that where things
were sort of invented but not really
contextualized properly i mean i for
some reason i'm thinking of
a person called what was his first name
baron von struckelberg was his uh
sort of some version was a physicist
who was swiss physicist
who invented various things related to
you know feynman diagrams of
normalization
uh i think uh
antimatter kinds of things i think
um and as is always
you know said to be a person who who
sort of didn't get recognized but but
you know if you look at the papers
they're they're pretty obscure um and
they're pretty hard to understand
because
they don't well you know again it's it's
a thing where history is sort of written
by the victors because nowadays you know
we know the notation of finding diagrams
and things like this for particle
physics we don't know the stuckelberg
notation
um
similarly a person called julian
schwinger who is another physicist sort
of at the same time with his source
theory um much better known physicist
but still source theory is you know it's
difficult to read for you know your
average physicist type because it didn't
become the kind of winning uh you know
most taught way of presenting things
whether that was wrong or right i'm i'm
not completely sure i think i think um i
think there was some greater clarity of
the methods that did win out but that's
a place where things can sort of get
lost
i think that there's a there's a
question of whether there were kind of
ideas that were sort of thought to be so
shocking that they were kind of um
hidden away
um i think uh
you know there's certainly claims that
get made occasionally like public key
cryptography it's sometimes claimed that
the uh british um
uh cryptography government cryptography
operation had invented public key
cryptography before it was kind of
publicly invented in the beginning of
the 1980s by um uh by ron rivest and um
ali shamir and um uh len adelman
um the uh that um that sort of that have
been invented by sort of government
scientists behind closed doors before it
was invented in the public eye
um and and uh whether
you know
i think in a case like that
there's sort of a question
of
you know
maybe it had been invented but people
said i don't know why we care about it
until people like what diffie had sort
of figured out the concept of public key
cryptography and sort of what why it was
important to have a separate private key
and public key and what the kind of
workflows that might be possible from
that were then the pure invention of oh
you can use factory numbers as a way to
make codes might not have seemed
terribly significant
um you know i think in
well
in some of my own work
about how simple programs can lead to
very complicated behavior
there are plenty of examples of where
people had uh
seen examples of that phenomenon but
completely ignored it just like oh it's
a nuisance you know in this case you get
this kind of random stuff going on but
we don't care what we concentrate on is
some particular regularity that we can
analyze spectacular example be of being
the distribution of prime numbers which
has sort of a lot of apparent randomness
in it but what people have always
concentrated on in the sort of
traditional mathematical literature is
things like the prime number theorem and
things like this where once talking
about the smooth distribution of density
of primes not all the wiggles and
thinking about you know what does it
mean that there are all these wiggles
and all this randomness
i'll give you another example that comes
to mind
so fractals nested patterns
uh very much emphasized by
benoit mandelbrot starting in the end of
the 1970s and uh
sort of you know fractals for everything
pictures of fractals and so on so i i
was curious when was the first sort of
fractal created you know the first you
know nested triangle sepinski gasket or
something like that the first one i've
been able to find was created in
about 1205 a.d
um in that i could find uh in fact i
went to see it years ago in a church in
anagony near near rome
um
that was briefly the the place where the
pope lived at some point maybe even
around the 1200s
and
it's a place where there was a family of
mosaic layers called the cosmoti
who were a pretty international
operation
laying mosaics in westminster abbey and
in this place and that place but but
they they laid a mosaic
in this church in agony and it has a
nested pattern in it and you can kind of
see in the crypt below the main church
you can kind of see where they were
trying out their patterns and you can
see because it's in mosaic and it's it's
there for all time probably um you can
see kind of the beginnings of the
nesting and then they add a little bit
and then they add a bit and you can kind
of see and also the names of the people
are there kind of uh carved in stone so
you can kind of trace the family tree
and i think it was cosmo cosmeti um who
was the person who probably originally
sort of discovered the the nested
pattern
but from 1200
to
basically the beginning of the 1900s and
really until the 1970s nested patterns
gone
uh you just don't see evidence of that
and in fact i was curious what did the
art historians say about the cosmoti uh
work uh mosaics and they talk about a
lot of the representational things
although you've got a picture of a lion
in that you know there are nice
versions of the cosmetic patterns in
venice for example there are you know a
great you know a lion there there's some
geometrical figures there and so on but
they just don't mention these nested
patterns because i think art historians
of before sort of the fractal era were
not primed to think about those kinds of
patterns and they were just like well
that's just a decoration like you might
have some
some periodic border that has some
particular form rather than another and
they just they just didn't mention that
so it's a place where i think
you know fractals arguably were sort of
lost for 800 years now in fact they came
back the beginning of the 1900s as kind
of things related to kind of counter
examples to calculus clutch curves and
things which are these kind of
snowflake-like um sort of curves with
with with uh an infinite number of sort
of extra protrusions in them or uh later
on menger sponges things like this
uh sapinsky gaskets for that matter
these were things that were being
invented as people tried to understand
the concept of continuity in calculus
and tried to be more precise about about
what kinds of functions calculus applied
to and how wild the curve could be and
still be meaningful from point of view
of calculus those things again were sort
of uh discussed in the beginning of the
1900s in 1900 1910 those kinds of times
um but again they were just sort of
hidden away in some in some article
where the main point was something about
the study of continuity and calculus and
it took until then why mandelbrot kind
of said well there's this whole class of
things that are nested patterns that are
relevant to understand the natural world
for example for that to become visible
again so those are those are some kinds
of places where where sort of scientific
knowledge gets gets lost
i mean i think that there are um there
are certainly plenty of examples where
people
uh
you know there's a certain
to my mind
well for example right now i'm i'm
um making use of a whole bunch of stuff
from mathematical logic that's mostly
from basically 100 years ago a little
bit less than 100 years ago in some
cases and some of that knowledge is i
won't be at all surprised if there are
things that people have studied that are
really quite lost and the notation is
pretty obscure it's not very easy to
index the the things are not well named
there aren't really names for a lot of
these things it's like what does it
really mean when you're evaluating
functions in this order rather than that
order those don't have common sort of
names for what's going on so you can't
really search for those things and i
won't be at all surprised if there's
something there that um that sort of
arises now i mean in fact
uh i would say that combinators which
i've studied quite a bit which come from
1920 uh the work of moses sean finkel
which were kind of the earliest examples
of universal computation but were are
very hard for us humans to understand
and really even today they are
challenging things to understand
and they were not understood and for
example when
when well even kurt godel came along in
1931 with girls theorem and general
recursive functions but later when alan
turing came along in 1936 with turing
machines
these people were sort of vaguely aware
of combinations but i don't think they
really understood them in a serious way
and i think that the um that was a case
where that was sort of a lost
certainly the motivation of combinators
i think was was pretty much lost
and in a sense
uh you know maybe i don't know whether
touring knew about them when he first
wrote about touring machines in 1936. he
certainly knew about them by the time he
was being a graduate student with alonzo
church
in princeton
in uh when was that must have been
when was that was that nineteen no 1938
was when when he was there right it was
before world war ii broke out
um
at least before the uk got into world
war ii
um
in any case the the the um
uh
uh so yeah those are a few examples i
can immediately think of
um
let's see
um
mikhail asks what is the history of the
ivy league why are those universities so
prestigious
okay well i i i'd have to look up the um
the precise definition of the ivy league
and so on but but i think it's it's
worth understanding
that
if you look at the universities that
existed i happened to notice this 100
years ago
okay what universities existed
most of the top universities 100 years
ago are the same as the top universities
today with a few exceptions
uh for example i think um at the time
then like the university of chicago was
still very new then a very kind of uh
sort of slightly differently configured
more science-oriented university um but
something like harvard
is has been around a long time i mean
since what the 1600s or something um i
think harvard famously i i don't know if
this is an apocryphal story that that
harvard offered a professorship to
galileo
who died in 1642 so they must have been
around before then and he said oh no no
i'm i'm too old and whatever i think
sometime when when i turned down a job
at that university that there was some
um uh you know galileo did the same
thing type thing um that was a long time
ago
the the um
uh
it was um uh but but those
um
uh those things um
you know the the fact that there's been
sort of a
a considerable degree of constancy in
sort of the top universities at least
over 100 years but there were a few
other few universities that were sort of
on the list of top universities 100
years ago that have kind of vanished
without trace it is always interesting
what causes things like universities to
kind of go up and down
and sometimes you know some universities
will be tremendously strong in let's say
chemistry or something
and uh tremendously strong in some in
mathematics or something like this
and not so strong in other areas and how
does that tend to happen it usually
happens because there's one sort of good
leader of that particular uh you know
area who comes in and they hire a bunch
of people
and the time scales you know the sort of
the the ten year time scale is long so
to speak and so people will you know it
will
once once you've built up some group it
probably lasts for quite a while i i
know well an example of a
curious example i worked at the
institute
institute for advanced study in
princeton in the early 1980s
um and uh that was sort of an
interesting case of you know what was
the uh you know uh sort of how
successful
was the organization and you know over
what period of time and what had
happened and so on that organization got
its start in the 1930s
it was originally funded by the i guess
the family that um did the macy's
department stores um
the um
uh and they
brought in a chat called abraham flexner
who i think involved in
in uh the creation of a bunch of medical
schools in the u.s
and he was sort of their main advisor or
something maybe the first director of
the thing i can't remember um that uh
and it was a time when there were
a lot of particularly jewish scientists
who were
being
leaving
germany and so on and uh the institute
kind of as many other places in the u.s
kind of took advantage of that to uh to
get lots of lots of talent
and the sort of the anchor
early talent for the institute study was
albert einstein um and uh
and sort of around him a whole bunch of
other people
but um you know so there was sort of an
early time when that when immediately
this place went from kind of nobody ever
heard of it it was nothing to oh it's
this place where you know einstein is
working and einstein was very very
famous in the public eye um as well as
among scientists
um and subsequently you know kurt godel
went there as well although he was not
kurt godel was not treated very well at
the institute and i think i think they
didn't really understand him and they
didn't really um uh
i think they didn't really
know whether he was a big deal or not in
some sense
um
but uh
uh
you know then then
years go by
and uh you know by the 1950s um a bunch
of those sort of the early folk von
neumanns the the einsteins and so on uh
are dying
and um sort of there's a there's a sort
of um uh you know what's the what's the
regeneration plan well it turned out
around that time robert oppenheimer
who'd been the scientific director of
the manhattan project
had sort of uh uh you know as as time
went on and and sort of uh uh you know
there was a whole you know was robert
oppenheimer who'd been
spent a lot of time in berkeley and so
on you know was he really
uh in with the communists who were by
that point that the big enemies and so
on and and eventually in in a sort of
piece of of uh
interesting sort of tale i don't know
all the details of it uh famously uh
oppenheimer lost his security clearance
and so the i think i think um
uh was his name groves the the general
who'd been responsible for sort of the
the operational side of the manhattan
project i guess his gig right before the
manhattan project was building building
the pentagon as a as a building physical
building in in the dc area um and then
he went on to to do the the manhattan
project but i think through him and
maybe a chap called strauss what was the
role of strauss he was a
maybe the
run ran the atomic energy commission
perhaps
anyway somehow oppenheimer kind of got
the the gig after he was sort of ejected
from the from the nuclear weapons
program and los alamos and so on got the
gig of running the institute for
advanced study in princeton
um and uh oppenheimer was i think a a
serious
you know
uh talent spotting kind of person and so
he made a big
effort to kind of find the best and the
brightest from around the world in
physics uh particularly and brought them
to the institute which he did very
successfully
the only problem was that after
oppenheimer died in 1968 or so um it was
there was this kind of gradual attrition
and you know as sometimes happens in
these things the people who were the
more successful physicists had all kinds
of opportunities to go in other places
and so they left them by the time i was
there it was it had sort of decayed down
to the people who oppenheimer had hired
who hadn't gotten other gigs so to speak
uh some fine people and and some in my
opinion not so fine people but um the uh
um
but you know it's a sort of an example
of how the urban flow of these
institutions works
um i don't know i i think the institute
has hired lots of lots of terrific
people since then but i don't i don't
really know
i don't know the details of it
but um the uh
uh i think
you know these
these different universities
have
you know there's always the question of
okay some of them have huge endowments
some of them do not have such big
endowments
you know what's the what's the effect of
that on the actual operation of the
university other than pride and so on
you know i was i was kind of struck when
i was an undergraduate in oxford um i
was at a college called saint john's
college
and uh you know there are
20 colleges something in oxford and they
all have different buildings and
different locations and different people
who work there and so on and you know it
to me it always just seemed like well
there's all these different colleges i
mean i grew up in oxford so i sort of
knew the physical place of all these
various colleges and um uh the one i was
at was nice and conveniently near the
physics buildings and so on but um uh
you know it didn't they didn't you know
they clearly all had different
personalities but it wasn't clear there
was much to choose between them and i i
only amazingly sort of decades later
discovered that st john's college was
one that owned a whole bunch of real
estate and was by far the richest of
these colleges and i just didn't know
that um and the fact that that was so
invisible was sort of an interesting
thing i mean of course one of the the
the funny things about some colleges in
oxford is that one of the colleges
called new college which you might think
was like the modern forward-looking
current college but of course it was
called new college because it was the
second college that was created when
oxford university started growing in the
1200s and so it's kind of like be
careful what you call new um and it's uh
um
i think you know things can be new in
their time uh and uh well just like i
was mentioning modern physics which is
now 100 years old and where i i like to
think that our current physics project
might be the modern modern physics so to
speak and so eventually in time maybe
it'll take another 100 years what is now
called modern physics will probably have
to be given a different name
but um uh you know i think um
the uh
uh
this question about um
kind of the
uh it's always funny with the prestige
of things like universities um
the uh
there's this funny lag because people
will know about like if you ask me
probably about some universities i might
have current information but my
information might also be 25 years out
of date um and there's sort of this
strange lag between the reality
and and uh
what people remember about universities
or what people know about them and i
think i would say that the the the
challenge always with um
uh
with any organization that gets large
you know it's like well there was a
question with the universities like the
who's in charge question
like you know there are university
presidents i think sometimes are a
rather
uh
embattled lot because it's like go out
and raise money for for the university
and like well a person might say well i
want to be in charge of what's actually
happening at the university oh no no
you've got you know hundreds thousands
of tenured faculty and uh you know you
can't really tell them at all what to do
so it's it's not really it's not sort of
a ceo position in the same kind of way
that it might be in a more corporate
setting and i think it's then then the
question really is what determines kind
of the um
there are many different forces acting
on universities and it's kind of then
what determines kind of uh uh what the
what the overall direction is
when there is a new thing that has to
come into a university some universities
have had interesting mechanisms for sort
of introducing new proto departments i
think the university of chicago happens
to be famous for that by having this
concept of the you know committee on
social thought or or mathematical
biology or something like that which is
some kind of proto-department which i
don't know exactly whether it has a
particular kind of lifespan that it is
is chartered with or or how that works
and and whether it ever actually becomes
a department after that but that's sort
of a an interesting dynamic i mean i
think that the um uh that you know
there's always the
the question of kind of how
the um
uh you know to what extent
the university what is the role of the
university in sort of the the life of
the world so to speak is it is it the
preservation of knowledge is it the
passing of knowledge from one generation
to the next is it the doing of research
is it
uh the
you know
uh
you know presenting a certain point of
view about the world that will be passed
you know that will be given to its
students you know what is the role of
the university
um and i think that at different times
in history it's had a somewhat different
role somehow it always seems to be the
case that there's a certain
uh there can be a certain uh mismatch
between universities and their ambient
environment i mean universities
uh
in you know back in the day in the 1200s
and so on the scholars at the university
you know they will put walls around the
university because they didn't want the
locals kind of coming and the locals
might not like the strange you know
professor types who were at the
universities and they would sometimes
have to go you know from from paris to
you know bologna to to paris to oxford
as people got you know came out with
pitchforks and so on so i think there's
been sort of a long history of that kind
of thing it is interesting the the way
that universities have embedded
themselves or not
in kind of the things like the political
winds of different countries i think i
think it was a time in germany and
prussia and so on where the universities
were very uh what we would now think of
as kind of right-wing nationalistic and
then there were that was
probably in the 1800s early 1900s
perhaps and then uh you know in the in
sort of the u.s setting as sort of a you
know the big trend towards the kind of
the left-wing university for for many of
them and it's kind of been interesting
to see that that's that's not a constant
in history but that's something that has
changed over time
but i think um
uh this question of whether for example
research is a thing that is a university
thing it's not obvious it's not true in
all countries i think in in
like in japan i think they're very
strong industrial research labs in
germany the max planck institutes and so
on that uh
i think it's a little bit more of an
equal thing in germany but it's the fact
that um uh you know that particularly in
the u.s setting
that
universities doing research
and the government's supplying money for
doing research that you know
a decent fraction of that money is going
to universities there's also some going
to national labs and things like that
but the question of sort of where should
the research actually be done and is it
the right thing to glue research onto
the teaching function of universities uh
you know there are different uh
different things one could say about
that but i think that's um and sometimes
there are universities there's certainly
plenty of cases where the university is
sort of great for teaching
not you know not really emphasizing sort
of the the front lines of
government-funded research other ones
where it's you know it's kind of like
all about the government grants and well
the students yeah well they're they're a
necessary evil so to speak at least the
undergraduate students
so i think it's um you know those things
have changed now i think it's an
interesting question going forward you
know where should the basic research
actually be done
um and
you know that that comes back to the
question of sort of
why should one do basic research what's
been the justification for doing basic
research
in um uh at different times and i think
even the concept that there would be
kind of professional people doing basic
research
is mostly fairly new i mean there were
plenty of people like isaac newton had a
had an endowed professorship the
lucasian professorship that was endowed
presumably by a chap called lucas um
that was you know a professorship back
in the 1600s for essentially doing
research i believe i mean i think that
was sort of the concept and charter
and um but that was kind of the
exception rather than the rule
and uh this kind of bundling of research
with universities is not obvious that
that's the best thing to be doing i know
that uh you know to to say something uh
you know in my efforts to you know not i
i've not been an academic in
30 what is it 33 years now um but um
uh in my effort to do research
uh and
research and development and so on i
think at our company we both collected a
lot of very talented people and also
developed a lot of good methodologies
for sort of getting
high-intensity research done and and i'm
pretty pretty pleased with our physics
project in recent times and kind of the
research methodology we've kind of
developed at the company over
30-something years applying that to
something which i thought was going to
be pure basic research although it's
turning out that there are applications
of our physics project you know a couple
hundred years ahead of schedule so to
speak um the uh uh it's some
that that concept of kind of managed
research and how one sort of can can
push forward with basic research in
these kinds of ways
is something that you know i can see it
works
in the setting of something like our
company
i don't know how i don't think that
would work
in a kind of traditional academic
setting for all kinds of reasons and
it's actually one of the challenges for
me right now is we're trying to kind of
launch a wolfram institute construct
that will make use of kind of what we've
learned about managed research and apply
it to a whole range of basic research
objectives which have mostly emerged
from our physics project and it's sort
of an interesting question how the sort
of ecosystem around that will from
institute will work you know is it going
to be you know funded by philanthropy by
government grants i think that one's
unlikely um by you know some token sales
and crypto mechanism that's a it's an
interesting topic that i've been
spending some time thinking about and
actually maybe have some ideas about um
but that's that's an example of you know
what what is the future of basic
research and how does that relate to
what's done at universities versus
what's done in a more managed setting in
a more corporate kind of way um uh you
know independent of you know basic
research is something where
you know it's not like there's
intellectual property to own it's it's
something where one's doing it
because well because it's an interesting
thing to do and as kind of a gift to the
future so to speak because
while it might be the case to the basic
research as
uh you know has sort of near-term
technological commercial applications
that's not its primary motivation and uh
potentially those applications might be
you know hundreds of years or whatever
in the future um and so you know one
can't sort of justify things on the
basis of that alone
uh
the question here gosh lots of
interesting questions
um
from
o'flam
you know
how does science progress from
outside of the academic process
i think
i mean the the um
you know this question
of sort of who should do science and how
should it work you know in past ages
many scientists have been amateurs
many scientists have had
either they've been independently
wealthy they've had some other gig
um you know doing some completely other
activity
you know einstein worked at the um
uh you know the the 1905-ish version of
silicon valley you know the pat the
swiss patent office
uh you know doing
reviewing refrigerator patents i think
he even made some of his own um you know
he was essentially a silicon valley guy
who did general who did who did special
relativity and then went back to being a
professor and so on um it wasn't
actually silicon valley it was burn
and um uh you know the swiss patent
office but it was sort of the same uh
you know an analogous concept um i think
that um
there are
uh this
this whole question of you know whether
it's you know
the invention of the transistor at bell
labs or
some of these kinds of things which were
you know or bcs superconductivity which
was also uh i guess that was also bell
labs or was some
was that were those people at
universities by then i'm not sure um
the uh
in any case i mean there there are
uh
i would say that
if we look at the sort of stack of ideas
that make up modern science
um i'm sure i'd be interesting question
what fraction of them come out of
universities
versus
um
what are viewed as sort of government
sponsored things whether it's the you
know the space program or whether it's
um uh something you know some other
government lab or whatever versus the
amateurs um and so on i don't actually
know what that breakdown is and i'm sure
it's changed a bit over time
um
let's see there's a question
about from slayer about um
growing woolly mammoths
and um
the thawing of permafrost you know i
have to say i saw these stories about
how we're going to bring back the woolly
mammoths and they're going to change the
ecology of the areas of the world that
have permafrost and it's going to
sequester carbon and we're going to suck
the carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere
and all it's going to be good and i i
couldn't help kind of roll my eyes a bit
at this i mean it's kind of it's in the
in the in the concept of you know
understanding chains of consequences i
have to say you know it's a fine thing
to try and bring back woolly mammoths
it's kind of an amusing idea um
you know the concept that that uh you
know the um um
i i have to admit that i i perhaps i
perhaps i'll be um
you know at different times in history
there is a different kind of little
twiddle that people will say about why
they're doing what they're doing and you
know at many times in history it was for
the greater glory of god
um in modern times it's uh the analog of
that seems to be you know to make the
world a better place
and the sub analog of that seems to be
to solve climate change
um and i i find it kind of sometimes a
little bit eye-rolling that some things
have these little little uh sort of
twiddles at the end about how that's
what why things are being done um you
know i don't think that's really the
most convincing uh uh
you know uh use case
for you know let's try and you know
get willow mammoth dna and and um uh you
know put it in an elephant and see
whether we get a woolly mammoth out i
think it's a much more i think it's just
an interesting thing to do
um and uh uh something you know it'll
make a good uh
um i don't know whether they're the
whether the woolly mammoths will have a
good time living in zoos or not but um
certainly interesting things to have out
there in the world um i you know bring
back the dodo as well i remember when i
was a kid
there was some i i grew up in oxford and
there's a museum in oxford where one of
its prized possessions is a is
a sort of
a foot of a dodo that has been there for
for a while
um
and no doubt has dodo dna which can no
doubt be extracted
um
let's see
uh
it's a question here from aaron do i
think fermat really solved fermat's last
theorem
um
the uh so just to tell the story of this
pure different right that's his name was
a lawyer primarily in france
and an example of a of i think a a
quotes amateur
um
i mean amateur mics it makes it sound
like person doesn't know what they're
doing but amateur in the sense that they
were not
uh you know making their living being a
mathematician
um but he was a mathematician
um who among other things um studied uh
number theory and uh
um
let's see i'm trying to remember he
wrote um
uh in the margin of a book and i can't
remember what the book was
um
that uh you know this statement about
format's last theorem you know that he
has a truly marvelous demonstration of
the fact that x to the m plus y to the n
equals z to the n has no integer
solutions when n is greater than the
pythagorean case of of two
um
you know did he really have a proof well
it took until andrew wiles
in the 1990s
um came up with
a very elaborate
long proof
of um of these kinds of things um the um
of format's last theorem before people
kind of uh you know before before it
really was established
i think that um um
the uh
uh
the thing that um
uh you know did fermat have a a proof no
i'm sure he didn't have a proof in the
modern sense of proof
because
you know the standard of proof
in modern times
is
well
it's in some sense not perfect but it is
much higher than had been at previous
times in history i mean things that
would go for a proof
are you know there's a there's a level
of rigor that has gone progressively up
um now
i having said that i think you know what
people sometimes push for today is the
idea of you know these proof assistants
which are going to go from from the raw
axioms up to
the actual theorems we care about today
actually my own work very recently in
meta mathematics kind of shows the a
little bit the folly of that kind of
approach
because it's like well how do we pick
the axioms of mathematics
what really should the axioms in
mathematics be what really we're trying
to capture in those axioms something
about how we think mathematics works we
think integers work this way let's try
and nail that down by writing down the
piano axioms for for arithmetic let's
say but then the piano axioms as girdle
showed have all kinds of weird
consequences that are very different
from our intuitive sense of integers so
what really are we doing what is the
what is the base what is the correct
kind of uh bedrock on which we're going
to build mathematics
and sort of it's it's not
it turns out that many of the things we
think about as sort of human-level
mathematics the pythagorean theorem or
whatever else they are essentially a
cloud of ideas they are not just with
any given axiom system there might even
be multiple ways to formulate that
theorem multiple different ways we
represent numbers or whatever else as
you change the axiom system there's
still a pythagorean theorem it just
isn't anchored to the bedrock in quite
the same way
and so this idea that let's prove
everything from the bedrock well which
bedrock and what do you even think you
are actually talking about when you're
proving something those are complicated
issues and i think that that's um that's
a place where
where when people think about a proof
today
versus a proof
in in the 1600s
it's it's sort of a very different uh
1700s it's a very different kind of
kind of set of expectations now for
example i remember running into andrew
wiles shortly after the format's last
theorem proof actually i i had the
interesting experience of some friends
of mine who are number theorists who who
know andrew wiles uh when the whole
format's last theorem
story broke so to speak
he had all these requests for media
interviews and this and that the other
and um so
uh my my
mutual friends of mine and his wanted me
to get on the phone with him and and
kind of um uh you know provide some
advice about sort of how to deal with
the world which which i did and i have
to say i i did say you know
if i were you i would sort of talk a lot
about how difficult these proofs are
because you know uh kind of the the um
uh you know don't
you know it's like you've got a
multi-hundred-page thing and it's like
they're going to be bugs
and you know because i know programs i
don't know proof so well but i know
programs well they're going to be bugs
and he was like no no no no it's all
perfect and then then there was a big
disaster because there was a bug and it
took him i don't know six months to fix
the bug um but uh so i felt i i'd given
good pr advice which had been ignored in
that case but but i ran into to him oh
maybe a few months later and you know i
was curious to ask him so so what axiom
system no actually was not a few months
it must have been must have been years
later
the the um uh you know what axioms on do
you think you used to prove fermat's
last theorem
said i don't know
you know probably not the piano axioms
probably involves some set theory i'm
not really sure and i don't really care
in other words the what what is that
proof of fermat's last theorem the proof
is something which explains to
mathematicians of today why fermat's
last theorem is true and that's in a
sense a moving target because what it
might have taken to convince a
mathematician of the 1600s that it was
true is very different from what it
takes a mathematician to convince a
mathematician of today which might be
yet different from what it would take a
mathematician to convince a
mathematician 100 years from now
so i think it's a it's a um
it's a complicated story and i think you
know you see the the um
uh
the kind of
the
the sort of the interaction of these
kinds of things i mean for example when
euclid first wrote his elements of
geometry in
150 bc i guess um the uh
he um
uh the actual text of euclid is just a
bunch of essentially aphorisms in greek
that just say this is true this is true
this is true this is true
now they form a kind of a deductive
system
and he intends that they form a
deductive system but he didn't give the
proofs the proofs were added by later
commentators um
and uh it was sort of almost a book of
exercises here are 465 i think it is you
know theorems based on these 10 original
common notions and and postulates
and you know it is the an exercise of
the reader to to uh to deliver the
proofs
so
i think these things have have kind of
changed their expectations of over time
the question here
um
from garrison
what's my opinion on polymathy in the in
the modern age of specialization
i like to know about a lot of different
kinds of things
i've learned lots of different fields i
think at some level i have certain sort
of core meta methodologies
and core ways that i like to think about
things in terms of sort of breaking
things down into their essential
primitive elements and then sort of
building up to to more complex things to
say from those um but i have to say that
you know i certainly like learning as
you might be able to tell from these
live streams i like kind of learning the
facts of a lot of different fields and i
have found that to be a very powerful in
a sense meta methodology because i'm
routinely able to take sort of ideas
that are well developed in one field and
import them into a field that's never
seen those ideas before and you know
right now i've been uh most recently in
the last few months i've been importing
essentially ideas from physics into
metamathematics uh sort of
physicalization of meta mathematics
again it's just something a connection
that just you don't get to make unless
you know both those fields to some to
some degree of depth so i think it's a i
would uh you know i strongly advocate
the idea that um uh it's worth learning
a lot of different kinds of things now
you know
to it is also worth learning at least
some things to a certain depth because
there's a sort of a different kind of
learning that you get when you learn
things in depth than what you get by
just learning things sort of at the
superficial level i think for me one of
the test cases because you know i've
spent my a large part of my life
building our computational language well
from language um and uh for me a big
test is can i make the ideas that i'm
hearing computational that's my kind of
way of you know do i have this sort of a
bedrock on which i can put the ideas
that i'm learning in some particular
kind of field if yes i feel like i can
understand them and i feel like that
that's the kind of level of
specialization the level of depth if i
can make them computational and compute
things from them and figure out things
and really be sort of off and running
and figuring things out then i have
adequately understood those ideas and if
not well then i haven't really gotten
far enough
but i think that the the notion i mean
it has become a feature particularly i
think of of many areas of academia
that um the um
that the thing that um
uh you know people think you can only be
serious if you're hyper-specialized and
you're you know you you you know you've
got to publish what journal you're going
to publish that paper in i mean i know
people who've worked and some science
things related to things i've done
wrote great papers
and it's like and they they send in one
journal they say well it's not quite the
specialization of our job i send another
one not quite the specialization of our
journal and so on because you know
there's been this sort of structure
that's developed where you know when
science gets big
it has sort of an institutional
structure that has to deal with its its
size and that ends up with kind of value
systems that are based on very
specialized pieces
you know i think that's a bad thing in
many ways it is good that people get to
a level of depth it is bad that they get
to a level of depth only in this one
tiny kind of hole and they never see out
beyond that i mean i'm i'm sometimes
surprised it's sort of interesting i
mean there are
uh sometimes i've noticed at our company
um perhaps that uh you know we have
people with a whole range of educational
levels from
you know the the sort of high school to
the
phd postdoc professor types
and um you know even if you look in our
sort of advanced r d operations um
they're people there's a pretty uniform
distribution of different sort of
educational attainment levels and i
sometimes think that um some of the
people who get all the way to the phd
and beyond one of the things that
happens is they get more and more
specialized and um
it's not that they get you know they get
deeper but in one particular area and i
think that it is uh there is there's
certainly people who for reasons of
choice or perhaps uh aptitude or or or
something you know remain pretty broadly
interested in things and that's a that's
a super powerful thing because it really
allows one uh to you know that that's
where a lot of the progress gets made
not in the drilling one whole deeper and
deeper but in being able to see across
these different areas and make use of
things from one area to another and so
on it's sadly you know there are so many
forces that tend to lead to increasing
specialization from oh you've got to
take this particular class and not that
class
or there's a department or there's a
funding program that is funding this
specific thing and not anything else and
if you've got if your project goes
across three areas it's like well where
are you going to get funding from that
because these guys aren't going to fund
you because
they're not doing enough of their thing
and so on
at different times people are always
talking about you know interdisciplinary
work and the importance of it and i have
i have to say that by the time you're
talking about that in a sense you're
admitting you lost the game because
you've got you know these different
disciplines and you've got them all set
up and then it's kind of like can you
put a band-aid on top of that um to go
further and so i i'm i'm
you know it's a good thing to try to do
um and it's a good thing to try to see
how you support it and the challenge is
sometimes well actually
the the you know the big institutional
structures are built in these particular
areas where where you know where there's
sort of a commonality of of oh
everybody's studying that and so
everybody kind of knows the value system
for that
um
let's see
gosh lots of interesting questions here
maybe i take one or two more and then
should wrap up
um
well let's see
um
it's a question here from our conquest
how has our understanding of time
changed over history
well i've been
i might be the right person to ask right
now about that because i've i've kind of
been very much thinking about
kind of the role of time in models
in science
and uh i'll first of all i'll say kind
of my
kind of recent thinking about this and
then maybe talk about some more general
aspects of of time in the in the um uh
in in history i think that um uh
i kind of view that one can sort of
divide in a sense models in science into
maybe four
uh four paradigmatic groups
uh the first
in antiquity
no notion of time just what are things
made of a kind of structural model of
things things are made of atoms and so
on 1600s
there's time but it's a mathematical
parameter it's something where it's just
a knob you can turn that decides what
you know what the value of time is
then 1980s
a bunch of my own work
in sort of making computational models
of the world where instead you say
there's this program and you start with
these rules and then you run the program
and the steps in the execution of that
program correspond to the elapsing of
time in the system and in a sense that's
a that's a notion of time where there's
this irreducible computation that's
happening that is recording the progress
of time that is representing the
progress of time
and the big sort of fourth paradigm
thing that's my excitement of the last
year or so
is this notion of this
multi-computational paradigm where
instead of there being a single thread
of time instead of having these
computational rules that just get
applied applied applied to make
successive steps in time instead what's
happening is that there's a whole
branching and merging of many different
threads of history this is something
which sort of was originally i sort of
started thinking about in terms of these
sort of purely uh formal constructs of
things called multi-way systems but then
it really gets gets its
teeth through its relationship to
quantum mechanics
and through the realization that that is
it seems how quantum mechanics really
works
but then the the thing about this
multi-computational paradigm this many
threads of time is that in order for us
to be able to tell what on earth
happened in that system we have to have
an observer we have to have some kind of
entity that is kind of knitting together
conflating or something these different
threads of time so that's kind of the
the most advanced version which i think
has a lot of implications for a lot of
fields um the sort of most advanced
version about view of time and so from
sort of a scientific point of view
but there have been a lot of different
kinds of time that people talk about i
mean the the elapsing of psychological
time we we think time is elapsed
thermodynamic time the the notion that
um uh you can that entropy tends to
increase as you go forward in time the
fact that you know you you can uh you
can't you tend not to be able to
unscramble an egg you know there's a
there's a definite progression from the
order to the disorder and that's a
another version of time or when we look
at the universe the fact that there's a
expansion of the universe that again
provides kind of an arrow of time in the
in the universe but this whole question
about our perception of the elapsing of
time versus the elapsing of time for a
thermodynamic system versus for the
universe and so on i mean one of the
things that's come out of our model of
physics
is an understanding of why those
different kinds of time all aligned
but of course this one basic question is
what is time
and you know is there a
is is time
merely
a a marker of where we are now
or is there some sense in which in other
words is
can we should we think of the universe
as this crystal in space-time
where basically the universe is
and there is the you know the space of
the universe and the time of the
universe and looked at if you could look
at the universe from the outside you
just see this giant space-time crystal
which represents the whole future of the
universe as well as all of it in space
so to speak and i think at different
times people have uh different times in
in
a history of sort of thought people have
taken the point of view that time is
this thing that sort of pre-exists and
we are but moving through it and i think
this notion of sort of traveling in time
became popular eighteen hundreds-ish you
know h.g wells wrote its time machine
book late 1800's um that was this idea
that you can travel through time that
time is kind of a bit like space
and it's something you can travel
through
um as opposed to time is the sort of
inexorable thing that happens
um that's a that there was sort of a a
dichotomy between those things and i
think relativity in 1905 uh definitely
was on the side of it's just space time
and it's kind of just space and time is
sort of the same kind of thing that was
very much emphasized by mikowski
noticing this you know x squared minus t
squared mathematical structure of
relativity that sort of reminded him of
of quadratic forms and number theory
which he'd studied a lot and that sort
of became the elegant kind of
formulation of the relationship between
space and time and made time seem very
much like space
you know i think in in our models of
physics
now
one of the things that we've had to
break away from is the idea that space
and time is sort of the same kind of
thing and this notion that sort of time
all pre-exists
is something that we don't really
usefully think is the case
instead it's like a program where yes
you can work out what will happen and
it's a completely determined thing what
will happen but the process of working
it out takes an irreducible amount of
computational work and so you could say
well i've got the infinite thing with
the infinite amount of computational
work that's already done okay fine you
can say that but sort of the exploration
of it even for an observer exploring it
takes the observer computational effort
to kind of pick through and see what
happens through time takes the system
computational effort to build what it's
going to build i mean in a bizarre quirk
of history that notion of computational
irreducibility that i started talking
about in the 1980s sort of among other
things i think
uh probably was there was a a key factor
in in inventing things like the
proof-of-work concept for blockchain of
you know you're burning computation to
show you did something well you're also
in a sense burning computation to move
through time time is in my view the sort
of inexorable progress of computational
work
it's the it's sort of the inexoral
progress of computation the inexorable
process of working out kind of what's
next according to these computational
rules i think that's what time is
um is is that
but that's you know different views of
time have existed
at different points in in the
development of things and particularly
with things like relativity um
the uh
there was this sort of notion of the
space time space and time bundled
together i mean this this idea of even
the sort of the notion of dynamics
is something that i think is is you know
i don't know exactly when that
originated i think that um
uh let's see what was his name um
william of oram maybe
um
the um was maybe in the
1100s perhaps
was person who um
uh
was sort of a person who started talking
about
things like
make a
what amounts to a plot that shows
position as a function of time this idea
of things sort of as a function of time
things happening progressively with time
i think that
that was a slow thing to arrive i mean
people certainly had the notion of
diaries you know the babylonians had
their
for 700 years kept their astronomical
diaries day by day by day you know this
is what happened today this is what
happened the next day and so on um but
for some reason i think this notion of
um
of time
as a thing where perhaps its time as a
continuum wasn't as clearly understood
until much much later and i think um
this um
this idea
that um
uh
uh well you know the thing that really
came with relativity
as time is something kind of fungible
time is something which could be
affected by the who was looking at time
so to speak now obviously there was a
psychological sense of that that people
perceive you know time going
going at different rates i mean i've
kind of felt that as one gets older one
perceives time largely by the fraction
of one's life that any given period will
take you know the pandemic lasted a a
certain fraction of my life but a much
larger fraction of a younger person's
life and that's what um uh you know kind
of um uh has a uh that that's its
perceptual effect is some fractional
kind of thing and so you know there's
this notion of the passage of time as it
is psychologically and how that relates
to the passage of time as it is
physically and this idea of you know
when you see time being sort of fungible
to the observer and you see time and
relativity where the observer is going
at a higher speed will perceive time as
as
elapsing more slowly how does that
relate to kind of our psychological
changes of the psychological impression
of the passage of time from you know oh
we're an older person so time seems to
be going faster for us or whatever it is
um i think one of the things we've
understood now from our physics project
is something about how this relationship
between you know time and speed and so
on works it's essentially that you know
as an as an observer of the universe or
as a piece of the universe there's a
certain kind of computation budget that
you can use to work out what will happen
it's this kind of irreducible
computation that represents the passage
of time if you're moving
motion also requires that you sort of
recreate yourself at a different place
in the universe and so motion and effect
also takes computational effort and so
in a sense what one's asking is are you
going to use that computational effort
to work out what's happening to you
at this in this fixed place in space
progressively through time or you're
going to use some of that computational
effort to kind of recreate yourself at a
different place in space
and if you're using some of your
computational effort to recreate
yourself at a different place in space
that means you have less of it to use on
elapsing in time and that means that
time effectively runs more slowly for
you and that i think is the sort of
intuitive explanation which i've
wondered about for so many years but
it's the i think the intuitive
explanation for uh time dilation and
relativity
all right well i should probably um
oh wait there's just one more question
here that i you guys ask such
interesting questions um
it's uh this is a lot of fun for me um
gr is asking
uh do you think there's a limit
what do you think is the limit of human
understanding or is there a limit
i think that's a very it's very
interesting question
so you know there's so much more that's
known today
in the sense that you know there are
endless textbooks of every field of
science there are endless things known
about technology about about the world
about the universe et cetera et cetera
et cetera
one of the things that's sort of
surprising
is that education is still possible
you know maybe there comes a time when
there's so much to know
that you know in a human lifetime you
couldn't possibly learn what you need to
learn to sort of operate in the world
but i think what happens is that just as
there's more to know so there is more
abstraction in kind of taking what were
originally just a set of disparate facts
and kind of combining them together by a
higher level of abstraction and so i
think there's this kind of this you know
both the knowledge the amount of
knowledge expands and the amount of
abstraction increases and sort of the
the the equilibrium between those things
means that sort of the frontier of what
what one has to learn to be functional
so to speak um remains uh doesn't
doesn't you know dramatically change
but you know if you ask are there things
that we humans
will are just sort of inaccessible to us
the answer is absolutely you know a lot
of this computational irreducibility and
this sort of the irreducible
computational processes that go on
uh are things that are are really just
not accessible to computationally
bounded brains or minds it's as if you
know if we if we consider the universe
it's got all these things going on in it
but our brain is just stuck in this
small you know uh you know inside this
small sort of brain case so to speak and
it it's um
it's not uh it won't be the case that
insofar as computational irreducibility
exists it means to say that these things
which are doing lots of computation you
can't reduce all of that computation to
something that will necessarily be a
thing that you can think about in a
brain so to speak
so insofar as there is computational
irreducibility there will be things that
we can't sort of wrap our brains around
now one of the big surprises for example
in our physics project and one of the
things that makes science possible is
that there are aspects of our universe
that are computationally reducible
things like the notion of space you know
if our universe is really this giant
network of all these atoms of space
but at the level that we think about
space it seems like i can just move in
this direction i can move in that
direction you know as i move my hand
it's still my hand it isn't like oh no
you've changed you know it's all made of
different atoms of space it's really a
different kind of thing i can think
about space and motion in space and i
can think about that at a sort of high
aggregated human kind of level
i don't have to go down to the level of
the atoms of space it's very much the
same you know we think about a a you
know air in a room we can just think
about sort of the pressure of the air
and things like that we don't
necessarily have to drop down to the
level of thinking about the you know
trillion trillion trillion molecules
that might exist in a small box of air
in the room
so it's it's this question of whether we
are capable
at the intrinsic level at the level of
the molecules at the level of the atoms
of space
there is lots of computational
irreducibility which we can't wrap our
brains around necessarily because our
brains are computationally bounded
necessarily and so there's necessarily
all this irreducible computation that we
will just not be able to wrap our brains
around now the question is do we care
about the things which are part of that
irreducible computation or do we only
care about these very aggregated kinds
of characteristics
and the fact is that we care about the
things that sort of our senses have set
us up to care about
and
if we had different senses we would care
about different kinds of things
so if you ask
sort of what's the limit of human
understanding i think that
insofar as
we have you know we're just stuck with
brains
there's certain computational
boundedness to that
if you well if you ask okay well let's
say just extend the brain let's have a
you know giant computer connected
directly to our brains um and uh you
know what can we do with that
one of the things that i think is the
case is that it's a very critical
feature
of the way that we view the world that
we believe that there is a definite
thread of time that we persist through
that there's there's a definite us
and that in the future it's the same us
so to speak even though we might be made
of different you know we might have
different uh cells in our brains we
might have different certainly atoms of
space
we might have different molecules of
this and that it's still the same us we
have this idea that it's always the same
us
now if if there's too much of us so to
speak we've got this giant computer
that's stretching off into the distance
with lots of uh you know speed of light
restrictions on how fast the information
can travel from one place to another um
the um
uh
it's um uh that's a um uh you know can
we preserve this kind of thread of
experience this kind of thing that seems
to be an essential feature of our
consciousness i'm not sure i'm not sure
if it's the same us that comes out of
that picture and you know when we say
well what can we what's the limit of
human understanding if we define humans
as this biological thing that has been
delivered by by biological evolution and
as our current experience then that's
one set of questions
um i think that um
uh you know we can ask the question
okay so another question is if we look
at the world and we look at all these
different computational irreducible
things that are happening
is it the case that the slice that we
have taken out of that is the only slice
one could take i think the answer is
obviously no
there will be other slices
now for example we can see even in
modern machine learning ai type systems
we can see that uh sort of you know when
a when when a you know image
identification system tries to figure
out is that a frog or a turtle or
something it's making all these kinds of
distinctions
uh inside it for which we don't have
names and it could be that the critical
thing you know when you're trying to
figure out i don't know let's say this
is what i just learned actually
you know i've been sort of amazed that
uh
pictures of faces can be come the the
age of the person can be can be dated so
well and i i kind of um by by sort of
facial uh recognition
uh
facial feature analysis kinds of machine
learning and i think the reason is
apparently that there are just actual
things that change in the you know shape
of the skull and things like that that
we humans don't particularly notice
we maybe implicitly notice a bit but we
don't really notice you know in a
dramatic way but yet the machine
learning system is noticing oh yeah this
piece has been rotated in that way in
that way and and that's an immediate
clue okay that person is x years old
um and so that's an example of where
there's a thing that in principle
and maybe people in in um uh you know
who studies skeletons have names for
this but but um you know maybe that you
know one could imagine a word for that
particular aspect of a face or whatever
it is that is um that would be the thing
that would determine the answer to this
but we don't happen to have that word
and similarly in a machine learning
system it's making all these
distinctions but it's not clear but
they're not distinctions for which we
have words i mean in our language we
have you know 50 000 common words or
something 30 000 common words
and
those are the words that we use to make
distinctions in the world now one of the
things to realize is it's a deeply
self-fulfilling prophecy because once we
have a word for something then we talk
about it and we think about it and we
make things of it and so you know the
the the cell phone camera or something
before those existed that's perhaps a
bad example maybe a a a a live stream
for example uh before those existed
before they had a name
yes you know i did some of these things
uh but they didn't really they didn't
have a lot of a lot of traction in the
world because they weren't things people
were talking about once once things have
a name once things have been you know
once there's a word assigned there's a
word assigned because it happens a bunch
and it's worth assigning a word but once
there's a word assigned then you get to
use it much more and more and so that
means that the the set of things that we
think are out there in the world uh we
say gosh it's wonderful that we've got
words for the things that are out there
in the world
and uh look you know we can we can name
anything but the fact is the things that
are out there in our world are often
things that we have
are making more of because we think
about them because we have words for
them so i think
in in this question of of um
are there sort of different slices of
the world that we could have access to
that are capable of human understanding
different from the ones we currently do
i think the answer is yes will we be
able to sort of wrap our brain around
the whole
of um
of what's out there in sort of the
the the the computational universe
of possibilities the answer i think is
no
um the the thing that i think is an
interesting question
is as we get more kinds of senses so to
speak from technological devices and
various kinds of things how do we see
sort of the gradual
shifting of ourselves into being able to
sort of pay attention to other aspects
of what exists in the world
um i i kind of think
that
one of the things that um i mean in kind
of the formalism of our kind of way of
thinking about things we talk about rule
space the space of sort of uh
kind of moving around in the space of
all possible rules and so on but but
that's um
uh you know one of the questions is if
you were just transported from here to
somewhere distant in rural space
what can you do with that if you move
slowly if you gradually sort of change
your way of thinking about the world and
gradually change how you describe things
yes we can kind of hack that but if
you're kind of you know taken out of
today and plopped in the world of the
aliens or the world of the future or
something you know will that be
something where where you can kind of
connect those things to our current
understanding i think the answer is
probably no i think it's unnecessarily
it's kind of like with um uh
you know we we find motion unconfusing
because we move from here to there and
we actually have to go from here to here
to here to here to here you know if you
imagine the kind of the the well imagine
the the virtual reality you know
metaverse type thing where you're always
jumping from here to there without
actually going through the intermediate
steps i wonder what that's going to be
like in terms of of um uh well i think
it's often called teleporting in in
these kind of virtual worlds
environments um and uh i don't know how
that i i haven't lived in these virtual
worlds enough to know how that sort of
affects how one how one thinks about
things but i think uh
that um you know as i say there's a
there's a limit from our sort of
computational boundedness to our level
of detailed understanding but there are
many different slices of things that
will be potentially accessible to our
understanding and we
over the course of time we probably can
get to explore more of those slices
although i think that just jumping to
another slice is unlikely to work it's
more a kind of gradual process and then
again
uh within our computationally bounded
existence i think it's necessary that we
sort of have more and more abstraction
um in order to be able to sort of
encompass more more kinds of um uh in a
sense more kinds of knowledge without
having to sort of unboundedly increase
you know the question is could we deal
with a world in which there are a
million words in our language
probably not
but perhaps once we want there to be a
million words
we can think about things where instead
of using all those different words to
represent this thing that we now
understand as a related concept we can
just operate at the level of that higher
concept
but these are these are interesting
questions sort of what the what the
progress of abstraction is and what the
uh what the sort of limits to knowledge
might be and that's uh i i've sort of
skirted around some parts of this but i
think there's there's more to say about
that maybe another time uh all right i
think i have to go um i think i might
even be doing another
live stream as part of my day job coming
up next yes
uh computational language design up next
well thanks for
thanks for joining me here and
see